sei mesi larini tornati su devolution un
gioco horror molto figo
stiamo episodio 2 che sono un po come se
fossero dei livelli vediamo la
situazione che bello casa mia a quella
la conosco
c'è il televisore lei che canta che ha
fatto il provino bravissima lei
ovviamente bravissimo a c'è la
pubblicità dai vedi che anche loro
monetizzano se questo video supererà i
10 minuti e perché io cercherò di
monetizzare come loro o c'è una camera
la prendo ma porca vacca sono uscito
salve no no no no stai due liste perché
i sei previsti previste pure lì vabbè fa
niente io sono uscito proprio quindi non
hanno capito forse dovevo prendere un
oggetto solo kakà che kakà io ho preso
solo la la macchina fotografica va bene
cioè quindi solo questo è la tesi ma
house thesis satana is my friends possa
accendere tre candele in una botta wow o
quattro madonna record cioè in un
incredibile come stati a cosa è una roba
del vino
ricevete dovreste studiare un po
l'ottimizzazione degli spazi proposto
perché non è proprio il massimo però fa
niente
va bene fa niente per il corso del vino
anche se effettivamente non ha troppo
senso diamo c'è un sacco di roba qua la
valigia è chiusa tra l'altro quindi
ottimo ok diavoli la permesso face la
bambola aggiustando i compiti sempre le
cose non si capisce una sega è la
madonna stavi qua prima e farti col
possibile sei veloce porca vacca si è
riuscita non me ne sono accorto bello
che le bambole di saltino in bocca dopo
minuto carino con questo gioco cioè per
carità
salve ma l'avevamo vista mi scusi ma
grazie
porca vacca il pesce è morto dove è
sparita e morto il pesce ma no ma no
all'opzione pesce stato stava sfumando
bruttissimo
quindi ma che si apre l'armadio red cau
bene
chiudiamo pure poi chiuderebbe chiudere
no va bene prendiamo questo no minigioco
fichissimo che devo fare
ci dovrebbe essere una pallina però non
c'è la fish eye cenno invece non era
tanto difficile farlo perché ci sono
ostacoli il mio quello che giocava
bambino mamma mi era un casino c'era un
miliardo di ostacoli però sono stato
bravo fatto la madonna quanta roba
grazie le chiavi della macchina
quanto vorrei trovarci una patente detto
sì cosi sarebbe ancora meglio pure la tv
pure quello ma non ti stanchi mai tu non
c'è qualcosa che fai nella tua vita che
non sia spaventare gli altri o fare cose
macabre posso uscire sono uscito non
vorrei mai mancare di rispetto a darti
disturbo però sono uscito
e stato molto bello va bene ho preso un
po di roba rack e che è successo proprio
succedono cose se tra di scuola chi se
ne frega io sono passato un po ovunque a
fare quello che
non volevamo salire qua sopra ci sono
salito per beh vabbè giorno mi chiami
mentre imitare ma non sono divisi e
floridi a pezzi le culo ma basta dice
perché se li segue mentre girano non
sembra che girano se invece va dalla
nostra parte dell'incredibile bene basta
fatemi uscire basta smetti and finito
molto maggiori facciamo un'altra volta è
lei
aim del ragazzo che rubele corso
finalmente si gioca mahjong un bel
giochino
no io ci gioco poi no voi siete sono
sedie non avete le braccia non potete la
teiera la teiera sta andando a [ __ ]
vado spegne la teiera prima la teiera un
casino o la sigo rumore la teiera così
spegne s'è spenta ok perfetto gradite
del te no
ok quindi giochiamo basta
fittissimo il suo gioco graditi del
signore signore sedie no
come niente il tè solo per esseri umani
ah ok c'è qualche essere umano che
vorrebbe un terzo e lo faccio no va bene
io vado volevo giocare prodi sa che le
serie non sono d'accordo peccato posso
darvi qua questa chiusa grazie a dio è
chiusa finalmente il bagno invece aperto
no avanti chi ha bussato e da dove
soprattutto le scarpette quelle brutte
che che mi hanno fatto prendere uno
spavento pin o un codice voglio morire
la password e sul mio quadro preferito
va bene non lo posso sapere finché non
trovo suo quadro preferito sarà questo è
l'unico è un vinile non avevi che il
vinile lo posso mettere da parte non
ficcare l'occhio la non ficcare l'occhio
la non ficcare fai quello che vuoi
ok forse peggio ma mica spunterà una
faccia da un momento all'altro ma va
fai un rumore
gioca con me gioca con me gioca con me
amici non dato a segno fa parte
sa che si è incazzato cioè ci
mancherebbe
credo che secondo me una camomilla
quest'uomo un pochettino farebbe bene
però fa niente comunque la password e
sul quadro preferito credo che non ci
siano quadri ma secondo me potevi
mettere un pò più in ordine per fa
niente posso uscire ma non mi fa uscì al
ceo che mi ha fatto uscire
no perché mi fa un po strano se riesco a
fare qualcos'altro lui la madonna ma
ogni volta succede qualcosa qua quindi
porca vacca
mi sono cagato sotto non è successo
niente di strano quindi va bene va bene
vediamo cisco ritrovare il vinile dove
ficcare il disco almeno facciamo
qualcosa in più e poi devo trovare la
password che sta dietro non i quadri
preferiti della bam del making devo
cercare nei quadri teoricamente
[Musica]
ho già sentito stormare da catcher in
the grudge porca [ __ ] io lo sapevo
perché l'avevo già sentito però non sono
stupido andiamo lo stesso andiamo lo
stesso hai già sentito sai che fa schifo
quello che succede non ci andiamo invece
no andiamo lo stesso va bene la mia vita
una da anni ok ok a posto tutto bene
possiamo rifarlo se vuoi c'erano so non
c'è il contenuto di quanto è venuto
reacher vinile martin garics qualcosa
dice che non è martin garics tra
proviamo si sa mai non è martin garics
che peccato
per me è sì
smettila di no non ti a commerciare però
non ti accovacciare non ti accovacciare
non toccare
[Musica]
ok ho trovato una corona per trovare il
quadro maledetto un casinò a suite gates
ski quindi io posso aprirla questa a
vedere non lo sapevo storico eccola
posso darti un libro delle storielle da
leggere eccotelo il buon lorenzo che
legge le storielle allora c'era una
volta un uomo e una bambina sua figlia
l'uomo andò a caccia di cinghiali non la
fa la racconto io lo racconto io non
tutto e quindi queste ragazze come si
cucina il savoiardo con i fagioli fine
tulipano origami organi di tulipano va
bene bella ho raccontato una storia una
bambola sono molto contento
flowers potter qua devo mettere
sicuramente qualcosa tipo l'origami del
tulipano che cresce
no che affonda e non succede niente con
che fisica spiega mente come fa
succedere questa cosa quello che sbocci
meravigliosamente in futuro va bene
quindi è cresciuta dell'erba a perché ho
messo fiore a dirlo è di locheness o
cielo è bellissimo perché cresce bene
bene se l'avessi saputo prima avrei
preso un tagliaerba insomma tutto questo
non origami lei leggendo questo lei
leggendo libri e storielle guarita
perché stava male era chiaro
se c'è un
ma lo voglio subito qualsiasi cosa sia e
quindi scrit to lead
hai un frammento di quelle robe che devo
ficcare sulla porta ok
immagino che debba prendere altri due se
non la porta non si apre credo poi non
lo so però immagino sia così bene tutto
chiaro
mi piace quando dopo quindi in un gioco
la dinamica che tu vai avanti qui dietro
mentre tu non guardi succede qualcosa mi
è sempre piaciuta non solo tra un po
magica in tutto questo ancora la roba
del vino o non ho capito se ci devo
ficcare veramente del vino ma ma come
vago e aveva allora ciò che è che cos'è
sta roba è per forza ficcarci qualsiasi
cosa voglio
ma ciò ficcato le le le scarpette e la
corona va dai devo mettere dentro la
ciotola lei le tre cose che mamma
piacevano quindi la corona le scarpette
il vestito che manca il vestito
sicuramente nell'armadio che sta dietro
la password solo che io la basso non la
so perché non c'è niente sul muro c'è la
quadro sul muro il quadro è ferito e
dietro c'è una password che non lo trovo
so cosa preferito palco demonio mi manca
solo il vestito ma da io l'ho ficcate a
caso lo sparo completamente a casa sto
qua anche due ore tanto è meglio stare
qua provare a fare a caso che andare in
giro per due ore
notato non trovare comunque nulla
la mia vita scherzavo è fantastica
non ho capito cosa è successo ma va bene
tutto ok tutto come doveva andare
perfetto volevo proprio fare che sono
diventato un neonato deaths trending ci
siamo ma ma schio a purgare che essi se
maturi donna
mamma non farmi venire un infarto
[Musica]
ecco bene sono sopravvissuti o c'è altro
pezzo è mio
manca il terzo che theory cambi il primo
è che teoricamente dovrebbe essere
quello che sta nel nella ciotola coi
vestiti ciotola nella cosa del vino però
la cosa del vino c'era scritto che si
aprirà in futuro non quando ciò voglio
io
quindi immagino di dover tornare adesso
speriamo che i ragazzi che sarà il
secondo episodi devotion finisce qua
però l'ultimo sta per arrivare
spero vi piaccia iscritti al canale
schiacciata campo alleni la prima
ragione video e come sempre siria hanno
proseguito da ragazzi
[Musica]